- On this episode, a man I respect dearly
comes here with his tremendous book.
Scott Belsky's in the house.
I think you're gonna love today's episode.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is the #AskGaryVee
Show, episode 290,
two hundred ninety.
And where we've really gotten
with the #AskGaryVee Show
at this point
is special guests,
people that I'm interested in,
friends or curiosities
and this one will go into friends,
deep friends actually.
One of my favorite buddies
from the tech world
over the last decade.
A lot of you who follow me
always love to bring up the jam sessions
after Chris Sacca exposed it
in some sort of Vanity
Fair article or something
and it's been made out to
be way more than it is.
It's not a secret society
as I think some people like to think.
It's super not glamorous.
Scott and I and many of our
buddies at South by Southwest
would cram into a hotel room
and sit on the floor.
- I think it was actually
a bathroom floor.
- Who was in that bath that year?
- Who was actually sitting in the bath?
- Oh, I think it was the
cofounder of Product Hunt,
Eric, right?
- And Ryan, yeah.
- Ferriss wasn't in the bath?
- I don't know if
Ferriss was in the bath--
- You know what I remember about that one?
That Damon John came, do you remember?
- He was just standing there, right?
- 'Cause he was like,
what the fuck is this?
- He was standing in the doorway actually.
- That's exactly right
and we became friends
later and he was like,
"What was that?"
I was like, "Dude that
was like, I was like
"that's--"
- Not sure quite what it is.
- Honestly you know exactly what it is,
it's funny, I was watching a
documentary of Steven Spielberg
and they showed that those
directors in the '70s,
him, George Lucas,
Spielberg, Martin Scorsese,
they just had a crew
and there was footage from it
and what are they doing?
They were cooking in a shitty
fucking house sitting down
and talking.
What was it?
We sat there and we would
say things like Snapchat, go,
Bitcoin, go, remember all those things?
- I remember and I also
remember Gary's rules.
So Gary would enforce a singular rule
which is one conversation at a time.
You have a lot of people,
people get carried away,
side conversations happen,
you don't want to miss anything,
so occasionally Gary you would be like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
rule guys, one conversation."
- [Gary] It was good.
- It was great. And everyone
has something to add
so it's always interesting.
- One quick thing
'cause we're here to talk about your book
which I'm super excited about
and Vayner Nation, let me say this,
you've been following me for a long,
well you might've started
following me yesterday,
if you've been following
me for a long time
you know a couple of nuances about me.
I, it's not that I
don't, I respect everyone
'cause I don't think respect is earned,
I give respect, then you can lose it,
my dad was like respect is earned
thus no one has it.
But there are people
that you cross paths with in your career
that play in a different way
and for a couple reasons.
First, as a human, 'cause
I've gotten to know him
friendly and family stuff,
I'm just a very big fan of
who you are as a person.
But subtly more on the playing field,
Scott has had one of the
more remarkable angel,
and he knows this,
I'm a real cheerleader for him because,
and we brought him up already,
Sacca went out and crushed it,
I did solid
but you really destroyed
it like destroyed it,
not to make you bashful
and I won't even go into it
'cause I want to go into the book
but whether it's Pinterest
or Uber, Periscope,
I have emails that are
legendary from Scott
of like, "Hey, you should
meet the Periscope founders"
or the time where I as pretty
on my belief in Pinterest
in the macro
and Scott was trying to help me get in
'cause he'd already been in
and Uber where a lot of,
I famously talk about how
many times I passed on it
when Travis and I were homie homies.
So you had a remarkable run as an angel
and also was a founder of a company
that had a tremendous exit
and he executed it over longevity
and it wasn't a VC
financial arbitrage thing.
And just, I'm just unbeliev--
- Each one of these feels
a lot of luck to me.
- And by the way, I can understand that
but they're not.
You unlike me, went to a good school
and you could've gone down
the path of the cliche thing,
how old are you?
- 38 now.
- Right, that's the other thing.
Look how good looking he is for 28.
There's a lot going well for Scott Belsky.
Scott, but like I know enough about you
and I'm speeding up here a little bit,
you went down a path
that could've gone down
a more conservative path,
you could say lucky,
I could say you saw what the internet was,
you put yourself in it,
which then created the
serendipity of those relationships
'cause you could've been on Wall Street,
you could've been a doctor,
you could've been a consultant,
you could've done a lot of other things
that a lot of people of our age group did.
You didn't, thus I don't know.
- I'm always wrestling with two things.
One which is everyone says
focus on one thing, do it well,
say no to everything
and a lot of people I respect
are really good at saying no to things
and staying focused.
And then wrestle with that
versus following every fascination
and a lot of the things you just mentioned
were basically fascinations
that in some ways took me off
of what I was supposed to be doing.
Some might say, "Scott, you
were bootstrapping a start up,
"what the hell were you doing
"spending time with Ben
Silbermann at Pinterest
"helping him think through a product
"and raise a five million
dollar evaluation?"
I try to genuinely pursue fascinations.
And then I try to,
for good or for bad, rationalize
why I would be spending time on something
that is slightly off my path
and I'm always trying to figure
out how it will contribute,
whether it works out or
not, to learning something.
- I will tell you that I've become
so good at that rationalization game.
I'm in the yes business,
I'm always doing all
sorts of ridiculous shit.
- Actually, I saw a conference
room with a big yes,
is that what it means?
- Yeah.
I just think yes is powerful.
- Yeah well listen,
in improv, never say no, always
say yes and roll with it.
- And to me, the no players
are friends who are like
focus, focus, focus,
they're like look, look how
successful I was, I focused.
I'm like, cool, I said
yes and was helter skelter
and I'm successful.
I think a lot of this comes
down to self awareness.
I think when you can accept yourself
and for me you said a
very subtle thing in there
once you learn that you have
to accept it as a net gain,
that for every Ben meeting
that led to amazing things with Pinterest,
there was six others that led to nothing
or a waste of time or an awkward situation
or things that you
didn't want to deal with,
it's a part of the game.
- It is part of the game
and one of my favorite
words is the world parley,
just like everything you're doing,
parleying it or some aspect
of it into something else.
Everything is building upon itself.
Sometimes something that
I do that totally fails
only five or six years later do I realize,
oh there's actually
something I learned from that
that made me say yes to something else--
- Or no.
- I will tell you,
it's funny you said that,
the reason I jumped in there is like,
you know, a lot of my mistakes
helped me get better at the nos
in a world where I want
to say yes to everything.
- [Scott] 100%.
- Yeah, so let's take a step back
'cause I jumped because I love
you and I know you so well.
For the people who are
watching and listening,
who are you?
How do you think about
your comic book number one?
What is your origin story?
Born where, to who, how?
Give me the three, four
minutes, who are you?
- Who am I?
Gosh, I grew up in Massachusetts.
- Home of Mount Ida College
which no longer exists by the way.
And fun fact, gone, went out of business,
first of all,
it was a horrible college
academically to begin with,
now it's out of business
and today, this morning
walking out of my gym,
another personal trainer
bringing somebody that lives in my home
looks at me and goes, "You look familiar."
I go, "Yeah, I'm Gary Vee."
He goes, "Did you go
to Mount Ida College?"
This has only happened
twice, twice, only twice
in the last 20 years of my life.
The other time, quick fun fact,
toll booth in New Jersey,
pre E-ZPass, I'm old,
giving my quarters,
the guy goes, "Gary!",
I'm like, "Quincy!",
it was amazing.
Anyway, nonetheless, yes Newton, Mass,
so very nice town.
Newton always makes me
think of Short Hills
where Wine Library is,
so nice little town.
- By the way, one of my earliest memories
is maybe six, seven, eight years old
I learned that there was colleges
where you could have two year programs
and four year programs, Mount Ida,
and then there were like universities
where you get graduate degrees
and I remember learning
that and being like,
I would never want to go to university,
that's way too much school.
I want to do the two year thing.
So that was actually my earliest memory
is related to Mount Ida.
But anyways, so I grew up there
and father, orthopedic surgeon,
and I would say my work ethic,
every night he would be
doing dictations at night
where he would be recounting
the surgery and whatever
and the lessons learned.
And in the morning,
I remember him always coming
in my room in the morning
and be like, "Come on, you gotta get up,
"you gotta get going,
"school, you gotta."
- High energy.
- High energy and like always
about doing your thing,
let's sit down and do it together.
I think the work ethic,
I know you feel similarly
and I just mention it
because he's someone who,
and as a doctor he just, bedside manner,
the way he is with people and patients
and whenever I go home
and walk around with him,
he meets people that he took care of,
the mother or the sister
and they always remember him
and just something about
that always sticks with me.
But anyways, grew up there,
always had an entrepreneurial
instinct to me.
I'm convinced that I invented E-Zpass
because I always made stores in the home
and then I actually made a
tollbooth for the stairwell
and I was like, I'll
keep the stairwell clean,
I'll vacuum it and people
will just give me a toll
when they go up and down.
And then I realized that was a lot of work
so I gave people passes,
they could just go without having to pay
and that was way before E-Zpass.
- [Gary] I love that.
- Anyways, my whole family
was very patronizing
of my early entrepreneurial ventures
but in high school started
a little apparel company
called Live Big.
My friends initials were b-i-g
so we made Live Big
and then it became nothing
but we owned livebig.com
and then sophomore year of college,
I get an email from--
- When did you own livebig.com?
- Back in 1996.
- Very good, keep going
when I registered winelibrary.com,
very cool.
- Right around.
- You know what's really
interesting about this?
This is kind of super weird.
You were in high school
you said in Newton?
That probably means that
you and I both registered
in 1996, livebig.com and winelibrary.com
in Newton, Mass.
- Wild.
- I like that, that makes me happy.
- [Scott] The building registry was like,
what's all this activity?
- I'm trying to think about which,
was there network solutions?
- Network solutions
was the way you did it.
- That's how you did it too?
- [Scott] Yeah.
- The recall.
- 100%. Now had I gone
back there I would've--
- Guys, pre-godaddy.
- No it was a pain in the ass
to get a domain at that time.
- Yeah did you have to
fax something?
- There was probably a fax
with a signature involved
and it took awhile to process.
- Yeah, you youngsters
have no fucking idea.
This is our version of
we walked in the snow.
We had to fax to get our websites, kids.
Keep going.
- Anyways, this became nothing.
However, sophomore of
college, I get this email
from an RV company.
You know those big things
that you live in, right?
And then they're like--
- What do you think I'm
like some trillionaire
in a fucking ivory tower?
I know what a fucking RV is.
- Just making the connections.
Big live, live in something big,
they were like we want to buy Live Big
and I was like well, it's
not just a domain name,
it's a company.
And so I think I negotiated
a $7,000 acquisition
of my first company.
I was pretty psyched
'cause I was like
sophomore year of college,
my company got acquired
and my friend Ben was at Princeton
and it was one of those
moments where we were like--
- Were you literally walking around campus
like yo baby, my company
just was acquired?
- Kind of a big deal
but it was a first foray,
even if it was a very small micro journey,
it was a journey nonetheless.
- [Gary] It gave you a high?
- Of what, what do you mean?
- [Gary] Did you get a high on holy shit?
- I definitely got some sort of high.
It wasn't going anywhere
but it was a taste of
coming up with something
and doing something--
- Did that make you
want to get into domain
naming for a second?
That would've tricked me.
- I always buy names.
Whenever I had an idea,
I'm sure you're the same.
- Me too but I wasn't buying domains
like a real estate portfolio.
I'll never forget that
business 2.0 magazine
that had the cover and it
said fish.com, $130 million.
- We could have a whole episode
about the crazy nature
of the domain industry
and who the holders are
of all these domains
and the way that they act.
As you know, they're these brokers
who go around with cases of cash
trying to buy these things
for people and it's wild.
But it's actually amazing
that it's still around but--
- [Gary] Real estate.
- It is real estate.
Fast forward, graduated college,
always had an interest
in design and business.
In college, I studied
both design and business,
had to choose one,
ended up choosing Wall
Street for a few years,
had one and a half years on
a traditional finance job.
Hated it.
And went to my manager and was like,
I'm gonna leave
and she was like,
well if there was one thing
you could do in this firm,
what would it be? And I was
like, I'm really interesting
in understanding how
leaders make decisions
and how a firm is managed
and how problems are solved.
And so I got this crazy
job at Golden Sachs
in the executive office focusing
on almost like internal
management consulting,
when co-heads don't get along,
when clients are going through struggles
but they don't want to tell anyone else
but they'll confide in the
firm and have their help.
And that experience actually
was a great education for me.
- Interesting.
How long did you do that?
- So that was three years.
It was a great experience
and I still actually pull from it
which I think is rare.
Usually out of college,
you have bullshit jobs
or you don't actually refer to anything.
But fast forward,
I left and started Behance.
The idea of Behance,
organize the creative world.
I used to tell people
that and they were like,
yeah, yeah, good luck with that.
But Behance, long story short,
became a network of over
15 million creatives
showcasing their work,
getting attribution for
the work that they did.
Agencies typically take all the credit.
Usually it's the creatives
at the end of the day
that actually did a lot of the stuff
and now they get opportunity.
We were acquired by Adobe in 2012.
- How long did you run that company?
- So it was five years of bootstrapping
which we could talk about
forever, that was rough.
Two years as a venture backed company.
- Who'd you take money
from? I don't recall.
- So Union Square Ventures,
Jeff Bezos, Chris Dickson,
and a bunch of other
angels back in the day.
That was probably one of the other emails
that got lost in your inbox.
That was before--
- I don't know about that.
What year did you fund?
- I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
2007.
- Yeah I don't think you emailed me yet.
I wasn't cool enough.
- 2008, around there.
Actually the funding was 2009.
- Unless you want
to trade wine for equity.
- That probably would've not helped us.
Anyways, so yeah, that
was an incredible journey
and one of the inspirations
for the Messy Middle
was me actually thinking back
to that five year period of bootstrapping,
and two years as venture backed company.
During 2008--
- So the company started in 2002?
- No sorry.
So the company started in
2005, 2006 right around there
and then we actually raised the real round
in late 2010, 2011.
- You got a little angel money in '07?
- Yeah, from friends and
family but barely any.
- And you sold to Adobe when?
- In 2012, end of 2012.
So it was quite a journey
and I actually didn't,
when I was sitting down
to think about this book
which is really the aggregation
of five to seven years
of little insights
around people's middles,
friends of mine,
entrepreneurs, artists, writers
who endured and optimized
through a very volatile middle journey,
I was like, well I
gotta start with my own.
And I realized I didn't remember it.
And actually what I did
is I went back in my phone
through all of the screenshots
from the years 2006 to 2012
just as like that's
probably the source of truth
for where I was, what I was thinking
and what I was doing.
And I saw all the screenshots
of people giving us a hard time online
or people liking what we were doing online
or errors or issues and team moments
and tough moments and celebrations
and all that stuff
and actually that was the first moment
where I got the granularity
of some of the stuff
frankly that I had wanted to forget.
- 100,000%.
No, I think that's a
really interesting thesis.
I think that in general,
if you even think about a movie,
people can think about
the beginnings of movies
and how it ended.
The middle is a very
fascinating part of everything
when you look at it in its entirety.
A lot of times you don't
know you're in the middle.
It's funny, you're talking,
I'm like, ugh, I'm in the middle
of the whole Vayner X thing
right now, this is the muckery.
Me and AJ part,
and you knew AJ when he
was coming out the gate,
that was fun and dadada
and boy, do I think it's
going to be a monster
and so there'll be that part
but I'm squarely in the
fucking middle right now.
- I think that,
well hopefully we're always
in the middle to some extent
'cause otherwise what
the heck are we doing.
But I think it's also fascinating
that yes, there's all this volatility,
there's surfing endless ambiguity,
working in anonymity,
no one cares what you're doing,
which actually is sometimes a good thing
as well as a bad thing.
- I would actually argue,
this is a really interesting thought,
I know that since we've been
in so many jams together,
I know we're gonna go on a tangent here,
I actually think that that's exactly right
and as a strength
and I actually think that
a lot of kids right now,
and not just kids,
are actually doing too
much content creation
and self promotion
which is a vulnerability
when you're in that middle
meaning I posted the other day,
being underestimated is the great gift
and everybody spends all
their time trying to prove,
especially and look at the youngsters,
you're 22, you're 23,
now everything is like trying
to prove to your parents
and your contemporaries
that you're good
and you start doing a ton of shit.
To me, that's such an interesting point,
when you're in the Messy Middle,
I think being head down,
not being out there
and not hearing other voices
because that is your most vulnerable time,
is a strength
yet so many people are trying
to put their lives out there
that they're getting a lot of signals
and I think it's not,
I think in the beginning and the end,
there's a little bit more,
it's a very interesting point.
- I talk about the fact
that we're all governed
by the short term reward system
and from birth,
we're constantly getting
our parents gratification
and then the check on the test
and the grade in the course
and Fred Wilson, venture
capitalist in New York,
at one of our early conferences said,
"The two greatest addictions in life
"are heroine and a weekly salary."
And talking about unplugging
yourself from that
and what the implications are of that.
And I think that a lot of
enduring the middle journey
is about hacking your reward system.
But to your point,
you don't want to have fake
wins that are motivating you,
you don't want to put out content
and feel like that means I'm winning.
Actually you want to build something
that's lasting and real,
and actually I feel
like the best companies
launch without the press,
they actually get something out there
and validate it
and get something that's working so well
and I feel like press is relative
to when it's announced,
not when it happens.
- Got it.
Do you know I hate that
I'm ina point in my career
that anything I start now
comes with expectation?
Like one of the weird,
this is so full circle
'cause we were talking before we started--
- [Scott] Well it stops
you from experimenting.
- Well it's weird,
I feel like this whole sports card thing,
is kind of like I'm
sitting here and I'm like
oh fuck, I'm probably
doing the sports card thing
because yes it's out there
but nobody's gonna take it seriously.
Thus, I like it.
I literally have this interesting,
one of the reasons I think
that I've been able to navigate
is I hate short term success.
I was pumped with bad grades,
I loved being underestimated,
I loved being the wine
guy in the tech world.
I love being the wine guy in the ad world.
I literally am starting to think,
it's why I'm loving my global expansion.
I love that nobody knows who the fuck I am
in Singapore at first or India.
- It's also why I love how
you do the yard sale stuff
'cause it's sort of like,
hey, everyone's talking about big deals,
I'm just trying to flip this thing
from five bucks to seven bucks.
- Did you see that this weekend?
- [Scott] I did.
- First of all, the high
of finding that stuffed
animal for 30 cents
that sells for 27 bucks,
and the other thing is look,
I'm a little bit like
connect with your dad,
like I want to walk down the
street with my son one day
and somebody come up to me and be like,
hey and look at my son and be like,
hey, your dad changed
the course of my life.
That's a big ROI
and so the whole yard sale thing,
90 fucking eight percent of
the people watching my content
would die out of happiness
to make $1,000 extra a week
and I know exactly how they can do it
in a way that's so scary.
Retail arbitrage right now,
now let's jump to tech,
dude, you can't imagine the arb,
if you just sat at a desk with a computer
and bought on Ebay, Etsy, Amazon,
Craigslist, Facebook Marketplace,
if you just bought and
sold, bought and sold,
bought and sold,
including buying inventory on Ebay
and shipping it to Amazon,
you could make so much money, it's scary.
- Yeah, I remember an interesting debate
we had at a gym session a few years ago
which was is it easier or harder
to make a dollar in the modern day?
And I'm not sure if it was Mark
Cuban or someone else there
was like, it's harder.
And I actually feel like it's
certainly, certainly easier.
I'm not saying that it's
easier to make a lot,
maybe there's a larger
commoditization of labor going on
and that's obviously an issue
but I really do think
that there are so many avenues for people
just to connect the dots.
- Brother, the long tail of the internet
is grossly underestimated.
It's grossly underestimated,
the long tail.
I just I don't know what else to say.
- I also think that people,
I think that it's not just
about where things are
distributed or purchasable,
it's also about the curation
that happens in between
and how it's presented
and how it's merchandised.
So you can find something
that's merchandised in a shitty way
and you can actually turn it
around a present it properly.
- Containers and merchandising.
- [Scott] Even if it's
a better freaking photo.
- Containers and merchan,
I don't even want to get into this, dude,
I'm so into this fucking shit,
containers and merchandising,
I'll get into that later.
Messy Middle, who who's listening
in a matrix of who's the ultimate person
that 100% should buy this,
who's the next,
I like to think of books in
three tiers of a triangle,
the top of the triangle is like
this will change your game,
this is made for you.
Then there's the big
middle of that of like
this is probably probably for you
and then the curious kind of nuanced one.
So break that down for
me, one, two and three.
Who is like listening
and watching right now,
absolutely needs this?
- I think that the more--
- Oh shit, this is an ask show isn't it?
- [Scott] We'll get to it.
- Yeah, we're gonna get to it in a minute
but answer that real quick.
- It's good question.
I think that the more volatile,
the more this book is for you.
I really do believe that there are,
essentially everything
that everyone's doing
is either a venture or replay.
A venture in the sense
that it's going into unknown territory,
whether you're in a big company
doing a product turnaround
and doing something that's off the radar
and you're fighting the immune
system of the big company
or if you're just an entrepreneur
starting something up and hustling,
if you are venturing, this is for you.
If you're doing the replay,
playing someone else's playbook,
probably not as relevant.
I also would say
that in the volatility side of things,
the point of this book is
that we are not our best self
at the lowest of the lows
nor the highest of the highs.
At the lowest of the lows,
we're making decisions out of fear,
we're losing hope,
we're trying to manage
uncertainty and ambiguity,
we're realizing we have to
short circuit our reward system.
There's a ton in here
about enduring the lows,
mining them for the gems,
and building the muscle memory
to endure future lows
and making every low incrementally higher.
And then on the highs,
the thing about the peaks
is that then we start to falsely attribute
the things that we did to us peaking.
And so a lot of this also
is about looking anything that works
and then working like hell to optimize it
and it's ironic that in the messy middle,
when things work, we typically
don't do anything with it
'cause we've got enough shit to deal with.
But when actually something is working,
whether it's how you're
managing your team,
how you're hiring,
how you're managing yourself,
or something that's in your product
that actually is getting
a little traction,
on the contrary, we should
be iterating around that.
And so this is a lot about
optimizing the things
that work across team,
product and self,
how you're managing your own shit.
Then there's a final section at the end
called the final mile
and this is question and insights
around why so many people screw things up
in the final mile of a project.
There is the turnaround
we're about to launch,
we don't want to mess this up,
there's this self sabotage that happens
after you're about to launch
something to the world.
The questions of do I even deserve this
and then subconsciously what that does
to you and your team.
I share some stories in there about that.
- Give me an example, stick on this.
- Yeah, on the self sabotage front,
I talk about an example
of somebody on my team
who really in the final mile of Behance,
when we were already in talks
for acquisition and everything else
just started to do a lot
of inappropriate stuff.
And at first, it was like,
come on man, that's not good,
you probably shouldn't say that to people,
you probably shouldn't be doing that
with these team members on
the weekend and whatever else.
But it just kind of escalated.
And I really started to
get very worried about it
and people were coming to me about it
and I was really getting curious.
And I remember going home one night
to my wife, Erica, who you know,
who's a psychologist
and kind of talking about it
and she was just like, oh, this is easy,
he doesn't feel like he deserves it.
I'm like, what do you mean?
We're all about to succeed,
this is gonna be a great outcome for him.
No, he's not comfortable with it.
And at first, I was like, I don't know.
So then the next day end of the day--
- By the way, real quick,
just for everybody,
this is my favorite part about life,
she's a psychologist, you're
like doing this thing,
you come home, she gives you the answer,
you're like, nah.
I have buddies, literally
this has happened to me,
my apologies for jumping in
'cause clearly I'm doing a better job
than normally listening,
speaks to why I love Scott,
but the last week,
I've had so many people
literally on the street grab me
and be like, Gary, you say this,
my homie Jerome says this.
I'm like, well what's Jerome up to?
Well, he sucks.
I'm like, well don't you
think it's a good idea
to think about who's giving the advice.
Not all advice is equal.
I just love that you come home,
you respect your wife tremendously,
I know that for a fact,
she's a psychologist,
she tells you, oh, this is,
listen to how he said
it, oh, this is easy,
he's not okay with it.
You're like, nah.
- It doesn't make intuitive sense, right?
- I understand.
- But yeah, the point is
at the final mile, it's a
different playbook altogether.
- So what happened?
Were you able to--
- So I pulled him aside,
I pulled him aside,
I sit down with him at the
corner of a conference room
where no one could see us--
- And did you go down the path
of like you deserve this too, bro?
- So actually that's exactly what I did.
I said to him, this is a problem.
Here's the thing, forgetting all that,
I want to tell you something,
I looked at him in the eye and I was like,
you deserve this.
We have worked together for
years, you deserve this.
At first, he was like,
what are you talking about?
And I actually repeated
myself two more times
and he started to cry.
- [Gary] That's amazing.
- And listen,
I don't know what exactly
happened in that moment.
But I know that we
embraced at the end of it
and I know that things changed.
- [Gary] That's amazing.
- And I think he just
needed to have someone
kind of tell him.
- Validate,
it's validation.
- Something about it triggered
and it just taught me something
about the fact that when people
go through big transitions,
especially when your identity
is so tied up in something
that you're building
and then something changes
towards the final mile,
it is really different.
You need different advisors,
you need different,
you need a different playbook
and that's what it's about.
- I love that.
Do you feel that, has
anybody who's had an early,
I know this is just coming out,
is it out or is it
coming out next Tuesday?
- Messy Middle, pre-orders just started,
it's coming out in 20 days.
So it's hitting October 2nd.
- But you're being smart and
trying to drive sales now?
- I am trying to, learning from the best.
- So listen, I mean this,
there are very few people
that I would cosign this heavy
where I'm going very
interestingly with this
is I have a funny feeling that,
and listen, the problem
with Scott is he's smart,
so I'm worried that the book
might be too smart for me
but I actually think there's
a lot of nuances here
about parenting.
So you're talking, I'm like,
this is fucking parenting,
this is fucking parenting.
I'm curious to see,
I'm curious to think the people out there
that are both passionate about
their careers and businesses
but also about being parents.
I have a funny intuitive feeling,
and I'm dying to see in four months
when I stumble back to this
or the comments or somebody tweets me
and says, that was the right,
I'm so intuitively curious will--
- It's so funny you say this
'cause two things.
One is someone the other day
who read it at early galley
said to me, you could substitute
every business word in
there for relationship
and it would be true.
And then yesterday, I kid you not,
I'm talking to somebody
whose starting a wild company
in the fishing industry
which I'm happy to tell
you about offline--
- Interesting, I'm in.
I've learned my lessons,
where can I write a check?
- What he said to me is like,
I have to tell you the Messy Middle
perfectly applies to fishing expeditions.
I'm like, what are you talking about?
He's like, my father's
a commercial fisherman
and he always says,
there's great volatility
from the start to the end
of a fishing expedition
the last two weeks, deep sea fishing.
He's like, the Messy
Middle perfectly applies.
I'm like, really?
I did not anticipate that.
- Yeah, because of the Jets
tremendous win on Monday.
When you first said that I was like,
okay, this is the second or third quarter,
this is perfect for football.
- Listen, think that
with parenting--
- Seth, let's get
into a question.
I feel like I've totally
derailed this show.
What do you got?
- [Seth] First question is
from First in Line group
from Michael.
- Micheal.
- [Seth] What are some tips
for keeping your creative
team organized and productive
without being a micromanager?
I work to provide video
content for clients
and between editors, social
media managers and clients,
it can be a challenge.
- Yeah, well listen, I
think that creative teams
don't necessarily like to subscribe
all to the same system
and I think that's one of the reasons
why so many of these companies
that have built productivity
and project management tools,
it's never gonna be a
winner take all market
because most people talk
about switching costs
like investors like Gary
and I will look and say,
"Oh, is there a high switching
cost to this product,"
and we'll retain its people.
The funny thing about the creative world
is there's actually switching benefits.
When a creative team kind
of stops using a tool,
it's almost like spring cleaning.
Everyone will start to engage
and love the new product
which is why you go
from Trello to Clubhouse
to all these different kind
of methods and systems.
So actually, I think
that for a creative team,
you have to start paying attention
to the elegance of the system.
You have to think about it,
creatives are, we want
different colored folders,
we want to have something that
we're visually attracted to.
Attraction breeds loyalty over time.
And so if you're a
program or project manager
of a creative team
and you're trying to manage
them with a spreadsheet,
that will not work.
You gotta be a little
more creative with it.
- The only thing I'll jump in here on
is I believe the
advancement of technology,
a lot of people talk about
in the advertising world,
personalization.
I see Jets ads,
you see ads for beard oil,
it gets that good that we get there.
I think that's great
and exciting and fine.
I'm so much more into that in management.
I genuinely think what the
miss is in a million ways
is we make such general
statements about things.
The only way to manage a team perfectly
is to manage them on an individual level,
on an every day basis,
and having a pulse
of their ambitions,
wants, desires and needs
in an every second basis.
I'm not kidding,
that is how you actually win it.
Now, how you actually do that--
- [Scott] Yeah, how do
you scale it, I agree.
- But I think you scale
it with fucking people.
Just speak more often,
watch more often,
the way I scale it,
I follow my people on social.
I'll give you an example.
I look at review cycles here
and I see people reviewing each other.
I know that they're hiking
with each other on the weekend
which means that review is
better than it's supposed to be
because those fuckers are homies.
- [Scott] Mhmm, it's context.
- Of course, context is the
fucking gateway to all of this.
And so my two cents on this is like, look,
when I hear people say,
"Gary, how do I manage my team of 30?"
I'm like, "Go to breakfast,
lunch and dinner,
"make it a family, know shit."
Because things change.
Seth today may want more money
but when he starts a
family may want more time.
Somebody might want more recognition today
'cause they're insecure
or they want to leverage
it for another job.
Later, they want more
privacy and don't want it.
- I agree, it's on a
person by person basis
and it's a problem.
Managers feel like they
have to start scaling
every way that they manage as they grow
and in fact, to your point,
it's really about--
- And then tools become band-aids, right?
Absolutely.
- [Scott] Agreed.
- [Seth] Next one also from
First in Line from Waleed.
- Waleed.
- [Seth] "There seems to be a large gap
"between various industries
"in terms of digital marketing strategies.
"Some industries still
view digital marketing
"in a very primitive way
"while others are taking full advantage
"and implementing solutions
"from recruitment to brand affinity
"in business decision making."
- Business decision making, got it.
- [Seth] "How can we bridge these gaps
"and further the knowledge
of these industries?"
- I mean, you're the expert.
I have thoughts but go ahead.
- [Gary] Why don't you
go with your thoughts?
- No, I think that,
well my day job now,
which we didn't really talk about--
- [Gary] Yes that's right,
what are you up to now?
- I came back and jumped in as a new--
- [Gary] You did BC for a little bit.
- What's that?
- Yeah, so Behance, acquired
by Adobe, three years,
had the best time building
products for creative people.
Everyone kept saying,
because of the seed investing,
you've got to be an investor,
you've got to be an investor
and I actually made a mistake
which was I started to
believe everyone around me
in telling me what I should--
- Hey listen, I was a
very loud voice in this.
- To Gary's credit actually,
Gary knew better than me at this point.
Part of me felt like I had to try it.
If everyone's telling me I
should be a venture investor,
I should just do it full time.
Jumped in full time.
Three weeks in, I'm like, I'm
not building products anymore,
I'm not working with teams anymore,
I'm working in isolation,
I'm trying to win the deal,
I'm playing this transactional game,
I don't know if this is me. I
don't know if I want to spend
the next 15 years of my life doing it
yet I was at one of the best
venture capitalist firms in the world
learning, enjoying every single day
of absorbing from the folks
around the table at Benchmark
and then I had this kind of question
about but can I do this for 15
years and be the best at this
or should I go back to building--
- Look, I'm just gonna jump
in and just get to the chase.
My level of respect for Scott
was already pretty obnoxiously high
in the scheme of things
'cause of the serendipity
of actually spending some time,
'cause I'm sure there's
plenty of other people
I'd love to respect,
I just don't spend time with
people in the scheme of things,
and then who he ended up being,
the fact, I couldn't
over communicate enough
to the people watching and listening,
the level of the plum, plum, plum job
in the game of venture
capital that Scott got.
So I'm so weird that I
don't know things very well,
like you guys kind of know me,
he gets it, fine, I hear about it
but other people that I massively respect
and think are super smart and great,
were like, wow.
And I was like, oh fuck, it
must be really, really big.
To have the ability to land that
and then to have the self awareness
and be willing to deal
with the scarlet letter
that the micro community
would look and put on you
when you left it,
like dude, for you, I can't,
this is a very big deal, Scott,
for you to get it,
and then leave it fairly early,
very quickly in the scheme of things,
which in a lot of ways
could've been viewed as disrespectful,
and a lot of different ways,
especially in the micro
community of venture capital,
to have the internal strength
to know oh darn it, this is not who I am,
and be able to make that kind of move,
it is a much bigger deal
than I think people give you credit for.
- Listen, it was a, you could
have a whole episode on this,
but it's hard to distract yourself
from something you committed to.
I knew it wasn't right for me,
my heart just knew it wasn't right for me,
and also I wanted to do it on good terms.
I'm still a venture
partner with the firm now
and it was important to me
'cause I have so much respect
for the firm and the team
but I also knew that for 15 years,
I felt like I'd
hung up my shoes--
- So real quick
'cause I see Seth wants to make
a call, so what did you do?
You got out and?
- So I jumped out, I was like,
okay, what do I want to do?
What am I most happy doing?
Honestly, it's building
products for creative people.
It's what I've always been doing,
even though I had sold the company,
why do I have to stop doing that?
- So did you think about
starting a new company?
What did you think about?
- I thought about a lot of these things.
And I realized that my perfect happy place
was building products for creative people,
working with people that I love
and investing as something I do
as sort of the side hustle, if you will.
And so I said, well what's wrong
with just going back and doing that?
And at the time, Shantanu,
the CEO of Adobe,
had come to me and was like,
I'm thinking about this
cheap product officer role,
would you consider coming back?
And at first, I'm like,
I don't know if I would ever come back
to a place I already left
and extracted myself
from and whatever else.
And then I realized,
if I feel like there's a strategy
that gets me excited
and I have the team and the founder DNA
that I still have within the company
because of Behance's acquisition,
I said, why not, let's jump in.
And so now we're kind of thinking
about the future of the creative world
as well as thinking about this question
around digital marketing
and creative tools
and how creatives can come together.
Bring it back to the question.
- I don't know where the
energy was for his question.
My answer is, you don't.
So first of all, there's
industries but there's no,
this is back to managing people,
okay cool, apparel companies
have figured it out.
Not all apparel companies.
Cement companies have not figured it out.
Well there's some guy in Minnesota
who's killing it selling
cement on Facebook.
I think the answer is you don't.
This is what I love about the game.
I as a pied piper
actually don't give a fuck
if anybody does anything about it.
As a matter of fact,
I weirdly prefer they don't
because I so enjoy the merit
of doing right things and wrong things.
I will tell you all the best things
to my best of ability
but if you don't act on them,
I can't wait to see in you
in four years and be like,
I told you.
And look, you know this,
back to these jam sessions,
there was no bigger advocate
for social, for social, for
social in those meetings
in nine and 10.
And all of this was far less obvious
back then than it is today.
I think people always underestimated
the communication tools
and I think they continue
to at this point.
Everybody's so ready for
AI and AR and block chain
and so many other things,
four or five social networks
are literally dictating the behavior
of 7.7 billion people.
Communication, communication.
Anyway, let's get this call in.
- Oh wow, call in.
(phone ringing)
- From Massachusetts?
Name.
Swardiq.
- My home state.
- I know. We didn't get
into the Patriots thing.
You're not that big of a Pats fan, right?
- [Swardiq] Hello?
- Swardiq?
- [Swardiq] Oh my God,
yes, this is him, yes.
- It's Gary and Scott, how are you?
- [Swardiq] I am fantastic,
thank you so much for calling me,
I love your show, what you do.
Scott, I think what you, you
are amazing, Tiger pride,
I don't know if you went to
Newton South or Newton North
but I worked at Newton North.
I also grew up in Newton.
- Did you go
to private school?
- Awesome.
I would've gone to south
but I went to BBNA.
- I fucking knew you
went to private school.
I was so pumped as soon as
that question was asked.
I'm like, this guy went
to fucking private school,
I can bet the house on it.
Brother, what's your question?
- [Swardiq] So I am a male nurse
and I want to be the nurse guy
just like you were the wine guy.
- Interesting.
- [Swardiq] But I think
it's very different
and I think Scott's how he
rolls, where he is today,
he went to school, he
learned at the school,
and you just did it, you
lived it, you just lived it.
I want to know, would you suggest
I go to school hardcore
become the genius of nursing
and then put out content
or do my thing that way
or do I just,
I'm a nurse now but I'm just basic
just got into the field nursing
or should I just do
nursing and then like--
- I know exactly, I think we
both understand your question.
I'll let Scott go first.
- I mean I think the greatest insights
come from experience, not from school
and personally, I most enjoy following
and learning from people
that are having intuition
driven experiences
on the job, in the experience,
through the hardships of the day to day,
and just how they curate and present
and analyze their own experiences
as opposed to someone who proclaims
to be an expert because of some degree.
I'm sure that school within
the profession of nursing
is extremely important
but if your question is around
when do I start sharing,
when do I start contributing content
and becoming part of the conversation,
I'm sure Gary would say start now.
- Well there's a couple
things, couple things.
I want to give Scott another compliment.
It was funny when he was talking,
when we would get in discussions
in these jam sessions
about CTO structure, databases,
I would add my two cents,
I can tell you that any
time we talked about Twitter
or Facebook or things of that nature,
I could feel Scott listening
to me with more respect
than when we didn't
and that I always took note of that.
And when he just gave that answer,
I'm like, shit, that's what was happening.
So I think that's interesting
back to listen to who's giving the advice,
who's actually living it?
'Cause a lot of people
pontificated about social
and they were super smart people and VCs
but they weren't in it like I was in it.
Number two, I think that,
here's how I think about it,
I didn't have to go to school for it
because buying and selling stuff
or running a liquor store,
things of that nature,
that didn't necessarily come to school.
Sure, you can start contributing
to the conversation today.
My friend the mistake that people make
is they overstep their
boundaries of knowledge.
If you now document your truth
which is I'm a youngster in the field,
I intuitively feel that I
have good beside manners
but on the actual
tactitional part of my job,
I'm still in the beginning of my journey,
that's a very important,
I wish I would've had the opportunity,
I actually don't know what I would've done
if this all existed when
I got into Wine Library.
Would I have fronted
or would I have been a little bit,
my intuition is
I would've gone a little
Muhammad Ali with it,
which is like I'm 22,
I'm in a liquor store
and I'd kind of go with the
content of like, you'll see,
I'll see you in 2015.
But here's where I'm at now.
I'm packing boxes at midnight
because we are getting more
internet orders than I expected.
- [Scott] That's cool, actually,
to live that with you.
- No, no, no,
that's the coolest
and that's kind of where
I'm going with this.
I think you should contribute
for a couple of weird reasons.
Number one, in 60 years,
your grandkids are gonna
be really happy you did.
So one of the things I don't
think people understand
about making content
is everyone's thinking short
term selfish instant returns
of how many likes or will
this get me something
and I'm saying, the happiness
that it's gonna get you,
that you saw yourself
when you still had hair
or black hair or young
or when your grand kid
comes up to you and goes,
"Grandma, grandad, when you were 22,
"you were doing this
"and I do that too."
So much in the human race
has been lost in history
outside of very famous people.
Now we all have that.
One of the great reasons
I'm documenting everything
is that's how I'm actually
gonna live forever.
So I would document just for life.
Where you could get caught
and where I see kids
getting caught all day
is they're fronting,
they're making pretend,
they're posturing,
they're faking it till you make it.
The problem with faking it til you make it
in today's world
is you're exposed.
So that's what I would say.
- [Swardiq] So I just want to,
so that's deep,
60 years from now is deep.
I do want to say I am constantly
putting content out there,
Q the Nurse is my thing.
So I did call you about a year ago
and I was at like 500 people on Instagram,
I was at zero people on YouTube.
I'm way better,
the growth is slow, I'm
at like 3,000 on YouTube,
I'm at three and a half
thousand on Instagram
and I just want to thank you for that.
- Can I jump in for second?
- [Swardiq] Yes.
- And this is for everybody,
fucking everybody.
We have to in our community
stop starting with vanity
metrics like followers
because it's a terrible
framework to play within
that almost always will eliminate
the upside that you actually possess.
I know it's a data point
and I'm not saying you're caught up in it,
I'm using this moment to
actually help all of us.
It's very important,
let me tell you why,
it's far less about having 3,000 or 500
or 4.1 million followers,
it's more about a single piece of content,
even when you have nine followers
or nine million followers
gives you the opportunity to impact
or create or selfishly create the step
for what you're trying to accomplish.
Tomorrow, you may make a piece of content
that serendipitously leads
to the head of a hospital
in Austin, Texas to see it
which miraculously in this moment in time
off the base of another meeting,
leads to them reaching out to you
and changes your medical career.
That is a very big deal.
I gave a speech at the
Javits Center in 2011
when nobody really knew who I was.
I mean a little something
going on in Twitter
but that single piece of content
still has had bigger impact
even though I have a much
bigger audience today.
I want to make sure that people realize
it's not the size of the audience,
it's the at bats and the content
that can lead to things
like impacting others
or amazing things for yourself
and it's just a framework.
Because everybody's
pandering to the numbers.
People are not posting
because they don't get enough likes
and they overthink things.
People are wrapping their self esteem
into how many followers they have
or are checking their progression.
What does 3,000 from 500 mean?
That means I'm going
in the right direction.
What happens the next time
I talk to you in a year
if that 3,000 is only 3,100?
Does that mean you did worse?
Maybe you did better
because you're better at
producing contextual content.
So it's an important moment
in this conversation.
- [Swardiq] Thank you and I
promise this is the last thing
and it's a question for Scott
and I know you said you
build products for creatives
and I just have to ask
'cause I've been putting
out all this content
and I love putting out the content,
I just don't know outside of the content
and monetization sometime in the future,
a product that a nurse,
I do nursing news and I
interview everyday heroes
that are nurses and doctors
and people like that.
I don't know what a product I can use,
base my creative on
and if you have any ideas
that would be absolutely fantastic.
- I mean listen,
I'll give you a quick
somewhat self serving answer
but also something I believe in.
There's a product called Spark
that one of my teams put out
which is like a social,
it's for social media publishing.
It helps you put videos
with the imagery together.
It makes things basically look better
with less time and less talent frankly
and just putting out,
but the point is that
you do want to experiment
with the types of media
that you're creating
and yeah, I encourage you
to add the visual elements,
add the sound elements and whatever else.
I think that we all have to have
our own little creative team
even if it's within us
in order to put this stuff out there
and have it resonate.
But I did want to say,
as you guys were talking,
I was recalling the fact
that my first ever blog
was called Musings of
a Novice Business Mind
and it had to be anonymous
'cause I was working
at Goldman at the time
and we weren't allowed
to share anything online.
But I don't even remember
what the hell I was writing
but it did create a motion,
a motion of taking
something, putting it down,
thinking about it
and for anyone who's listening
who is like, oh, I don't
know if I have any content
ready to share yet,
I do think while it has to be true
and just sharing whether
it's packing boxes
and managing a big day of orders
that exceeded your capacity
or your communications or whatever less,
there's something about that motion
of writing shit down
that I think develops you.
- People don't understand,
people don't understand
that we have the advantage
from day one of being a human
and having our individual reality.
And everybody spends all their time
trying to take this unique flavor
and turn it into vanilla.
I'm watching everybody try to conform
into what they think works
without realizing their nuances
is what works.
Scott, I had people reach out to me
in our kind of circles
and tell me that what I'm doing
with the garage sale thing
is a bad idea
in a loving way.
They're like, Gary, you're like,
it's so funny when,
being underestimated's a lot of fun.
Having smart friends,
I think there's something
unbelievably still respected
about universities and schools
and me going to Mount
Ida versus Princeton.
There's an underlying tone
amongst my contemporaries
that there's still
certain things I don't get
because we grew up in a time
where that had so much value on intellect.
Yet the game's being played out
in such an emotional gray way, not that.
So I have friends,
so first of all,
two things I love,
people reach out to me like Gary,
you don't even know how much
you're impacting the world.
And I'm like, mother fucker,
I think I'm impacting the world
more than anybody does.
- I know.
- Exactly, thank you.
Number two, bunch of homies
reached out and were like,
yo, don't do this.
That's what you used to do.
You've got a big audience now,
there's presidents and real people
and they're like, if you do this,
it's gonna make you,
and I was like, you are so lost
in the reality of how life works.
- I think it's wild
that the more your
intuition works for you,
the more people start to question
the volume of your own intuition.
It's fucking wild.
- I'm sure you had a lot of feedback
on the decisions you made when you left
and so for me, they're like,
and listen I have more
empathy that you know,
if you're playing in that kind of cloud
that why is Gary buying
stuffed animals and posting it
and could this hurt him?
It's coming from a loving place
but where I'm going with
this is the following.
Because I'm a Jets loving,
garage sale loving,
root beer loving, wine
loving, entrepreneur,
these are the strengths not the weaknesses
and so where I'm going with
is if you're a young nurse
and you're trying to,
when you talk about a product like Spark,
not everybody has a team
producing their content,
so you're gonna need
to do different things.
Written word, audio, video,
but it all goes to one place.
When you have inner confidence,
like true self esteem
you will produce unlimited
amounts of content in all forms
because you are no longer crippled
by the instant feedback loop
of likes and comments.
- By the way, totally agree with that.
I always feel like creative block
of the consequence of avoiding the truth.
And when you pierce the truth, it flows.
- Period.
Let me give you an example, real life,
we are currently sitting here,
last night 11PM I posted a video
that was a minute and 23 seconds long,
not made for Instagram
and I posted it on Instagram
'cause I watched it and was okay
with where it ended at one minute
knowing I was giving up the punch
that the 23 seconds had to really kill it
which is why it will do better on Twitter.
I posted it at not a
great time on Instagram
but I wanted to learn what it would do
when I put a pice of content
that wasn't as native as it could've been
at not an optimal time.
It did not well
which reinforced my thesis
of native content and understanding.
It might've done phenomenal
like other times in the past
which reinforces fucking
break your own fucking rules.
Here's the thing,
if you don't have the
confidence to go there,
for example,
if I didn't have the confidence
to be okay with the fact
that my YouTube channel is
not being optimized at all
over the last 15 months
hence why it's stale
and if my identity was wrapped up
into how many subscribers
or likes or comments,
well then that's not what I would do.
At the same token,
by not being crippled by that,
it allowed me to follow the momentum
to create a top 100 podcast.
People are just confused,
they look at things in the micro
and they don't macro it up.
And so when I hear a tool,
when I hear his question,
what's the tool that's gonna help me,
where it really goes is first
get into a place of realizing
that if you're comfortable
with everything,
well then you can do
and when you do, you will learn.
- [Swardiq] Thank you
guys, thank you so much.
- Scott, parting shots,
anything you want to say about the book.
Listen, I don't know where it's,
where's it ranked on Amazon right now?
Are we live on Facebook?
How many people are watching right now?
Can you tell?
I'm looking at this right now,
I'm gonna have a little fun for myself.
While you're looking that up,
Scott parting thoughts on the book
while I'm looking at this.
- Listen, parting thoughts on the book,
I think one of the things I
tried to not shy away from
was conflicting advice that
I got from different people
that I interviewed for this book.
It was wild how I would
go to different people
who had started different
things in different industries,
asking about their middles
and things that they learned
and best practices and
blah, blah, blah, blah
and I would find things
that were the opposite of each other
and the question was do I pick one side
because I want to be consistent
or do I allow the reader
to kind of manage the conflict
and mine it for their own intuition,
obviously, I aspired for the latter
and that's the framework of the book
and I thought I'd put up
the opposing perspectives
right next to each other
'cause I actually believe
that that's how people
become great adventurers in the middle
is they are able to
reconcile conflicting advice,
they're able to reconcile--
- 'Cause that's the reality of the game.
- That is, that is.
By the way, if someone tells
you there's a best practice,
it's BS because anything that
works at one stage of the play
is the exact opposite of what you want
to do somewhere else.
- I always talk about
being in love with the fact
that I'm a contradiction,
it's my strength.
I can hold different things
and decide in the context of the moment
which one of my swords I want--
- Anyone can have advice
and that's the thing,
it's not a traditional business book.
I have to tell you
when I sent the manuscript
in to my publisher,
I'm gonna throw him
under the bus right now
but they came back to me, they're like,
um, the format of this,
it's insights, we want
a traditional narrative
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I was like this is not the modern way
that people want to learn.
You can say it, I was a
little nicer than that.
I'm so proud of this book.
I'm excited to get it out there,
I'm excited for people
to agree and disagree
and just hope it helps people.
- 3704, that is the current rank.
I expect the Vayner Nation
to all go buy three to seven to 11 copies
and give it to everybody
so that goes up.
Number two, he's Scott Belsky,
b-e-l-s-k-y, on Twitter, @scottbelsky.
Every person,
'cause I know this is
gonna go out in a week,
every human that buys this
book 'cause of this podcast,
I want you to tweet @scottbelsky
and tell him that the #AskGaryVee Show--
- This is the power of Gary Vee.
- 100%.
- [Scott] Unbelievable.
- I want this to continue
to pound your feed.
Thanks for being on the show.
Question of the day.
Every guest I have
gets to ask the question of
the day which is a lot of fun
because on YouTube and Facebook
and on Twitter and other places,
you get thousands of answers
which can give us some insights.
And by the way, it doesn't
even have to be about the book.
What burning question,
what would you love to
get thousands of people's
of insights on right now
out of more curiosity?
It can be as silly as favorite color
or favorite TV show,
it can be very specific to the book
or something else randomly
that's scratching your brain right now.
- Yeah, I mean gosh,
I mean one of the questions I have lately
is around these micro
brands that are emerging
and we all love these new brands
that seem to be merchandised just to us,
vis Instagram and other places,
and I am wondering a lot these days
around whether we love a brand
simply because it resonates with us
and it looks cool and whatever,
it's a sock company we never heard of
and we like the design
or if it's because of the community
associated with the brand.
In which case that would argue against
the sort of long tail
future brand narrative
that there will be a brand
for every single person
and actually eventually they'll
be a brand made for you,
it'll be marketed directly to you
and you'll just engage with you.
You don't care who else
is actually using it.
- That's not what humans do.
To save time,
this is where people
aren't smart about history,
it's not what humans do.
We are deeply inherently
in need of each other.
- I think it's community driven as well.
- [Gary] 100 fucking percent.
- But then I guess the question then is--
- The difference is distribution
and awareness has changed.
So they'll be options.
So it will be amortized
but not till, this is all comm,
Scott, do you understand that
when I walk on the street
and see a human being
wearing a Jets jersey
that I am instantly
family with that person?
The same way that somebody will walk
and see a star of David or a cross
and feel instant family
or pair of YEEZYs or a long beard
or a sleeve of tattoos,
we are deeply, deeply
in need of each other.
- Well then I guess
that's the question then
because we're seeing more
and more random brands
that are clever and cool
design and whatever else.
- Because the cost of entry is zero.
And so that's what you're seeing.
- Where's that gonna play out?
Does that mean there's gonna
be a million more brands
or that means we're gonna
fight our micro communities?
- Both.
You'll have more,
what we haven't reconciled yet
is we need a collapse,
we need a macro economic
collapse to reset.
What will happen out
of that reset, I think,
is you're gonna see certain people,
the ambition to build a brand
that makes you $88,000 a
year and you can be at home
is gonna get high.
Right now, everybody thinks
they're gonna build the next
fucking Supreme or Instagram.
That needs to die because
they're not going to.
When we change that,
when young Alex, 14 year old Alex, says,
"I'm gonna build a honey company
"'cause my grandma had honey bees
"and I kind of like it.
"I don't want to say that
in school yet 'cause I'm 14
"and honey bees for a dude is not cool,
but when he gets to,
one day I'm gonna start a honey company
and I'm gonna make $113,000 a year
after profits and everything,
and I'm gonna make honey
and I'm gonna have fun
and that's gonna make me happy.
That's when this shit's gonna get good.
Right now, Scott, the
entry to the one percent
income makers in America is 440,000.
Everybody in America
thinks if you don't make a million a year,
you haven't even started making it.
That's a problem.
That's called a delta, that is a problem.
When we get into making 113, happy,
is a lot better than making 209 depressed,
those people will start taking
advantage of the long tail.
They'll start being the person that knits
and makes 113 on Etsy.
They're the person that's
gonna love Star Trek
and literally live life day
trading on Ebay and Amazon,
buying Star Trek on Ebay for nine,
selling it for 14 on Amazon.
So those will emerge.
As will Lola and Harrys,
as will the person that should
be most worried about this
is Proctor and Kraft and Pepsi
because all of their infrastructure,
that's who it's gonna come out of.
- It's true
and they're also churning
it out without stories
and I think that can
come kind of full circle
and back to the messy middle.
- Scott, they're also at the mercy
of Walmart and Albertson's.
What people don't understand
is they're not stupid, they're stuck.
They're not stupid, they're stuck.
Adobe, Adobe has certain things
because of it's scale
that doesn't allow it
to play with somebody
who's in a garage right now
and does something.
It has advantages.
The reason you're important in my opinion
from afar to Adobe,
is because you understand that world
thus knowing the hypocrisy
internally of certain things
and if you have control,
and I have no idea if you do or not,
then you have the chance to actually,
what big companies should
never lose to small companies
and they always do
because they have audacity.
- Yeah, well I think that you start to,
the science of business is scaling,
the art of business is the
things that don't scale
and the question is how can
you keep making that happen.
Thank you so much.
- I love you buddy. Yes.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)